hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to your exclusive first look at
the lg g3 one of the most anticipated
phones of 2014 believe it or not so
let's go ahead and take a closer look so
i was able to get my hands on one of the
first lg g3s out there and i've had to
hold back and not tell anyone about it
until now so this is actually a korean
model but all the same specs and
features apply here and the specs of the
lg g3 are top-notch so it's rocking the
snapdragon 801 quad core chip three
gigabytes of ram and a
2560x1440 display that we will talk a
lot about in a minute all packaged in a
really handsome body in fact that was my
first thought when holding the lg g3 for
the first time was wow this is a really
good looking phone and even though it's
made of plastic the finish in the back
is pretty nice and it feels nice in the
hand it's actually a little bit lighter
than the g2 was and lg of course kept
the back buttons from the g2 and they're
actually improved a bit uh there's no
led notification on the back anymore but
the buttons are a little clickier and
they're a little more tactile they feel
good to press and they're honestly
pretty easy to get used to from side
buttons so on the front might as well
talk about it right now it's that
display it has a 5.5 inch
2560x1440 display which gives you a
pixel density north of 530 pixels per
inch in other words this is an insanely
sharp display and it's surrounded by
tiny bezels and a very small chin so
really the phone doesn't feel that big
at all when you hold it up next to
another phone with a 5.5 inch display
you may remember this one plus one here
for example the g3 feels pretty compact
compared to it especially in the height
department and i'm a huge fan of keeping
this design language these thin bezels i
love it it's actually more comparable
now in size to a phone with a five inch
display like the galaxy s5 or the htc
one while you still get this big 5.5
inch display on the g3 and there are
some other nice improvements to the
hardware like lg hearing everyone out
and including a 3 000 milliamp hour
removable battery behind this plastic
door and a micro sd card slot for people
who value removable storage although i
think i'd be cool with the 32gb model
here and it has a slightly new camera a
13 megapixel camera with a few
interesting improvements optical image
stabilization a dual tone flash now 4k
video recording 720p slow motion video
recording at 120 frames a second and a
new laser autofocus system that actually
fires lasers and uses the reflections to
sense and determine how far away the
subject is super fast then focuses there
and takes the picture pretty cool
playing with it for a bit i do think it
focused pretty quickly and the camera
app was super simple nice quick easy to
use it lets you take pictures by
pressing one of the back volume buttons
or lets you take a selfie by clenching
your fist on camera to start a countdown
timer lots of nifty stuff here but a lot
of these things are specs that i'll have
to test out more in daily usage for my
full review of the g3 so definitely
subscribe right below if you haven't
already as that'll be in the works as i
get to know this phone better you guys
will be the first to see it but let's
get back to this display there were a
lot of people talking a lot of buzz
about lg making a display like this and
whether or not they would actually put
it in a smartphone you know would it
hinder performance would it reduce
battery life would there be any cons to
using such a high res display in a
smartphone because to be honest right
now the pros are pretty limited too this
hardware is really ahead of the content
and even lg software is barely caught up
so you have some super high resolution
wallpapers of course they made them look
you know they have lots of dots and
stars and they look really impressive of
course
and all of lg's assets their icons their
stock apps all that stuff is super high
resolution but any other android app
like a game or a youtube video or
whatever it is
still runs at 1080p it's kind of like
when those 1080p phones were brand new
everyone had a 720p phone and we first
saw phones like the droid dna and
everything else around it was still
lower res so eventually the content had
to catch up and now everyone has 1080p
phones so this could be another step in
that direction
uh but what are the cons really well
okay right now there aren't really that
many normal performance seems pretty
snappy just like the lg g2 was with this
lg skin on it this here is on top of
android 4.4 kitkat and here everything
from multitasking to opening and closing
apps seems fine and at a normal speed
animations seem pretty fluid of course
this could change as i test the phone
more but it seems just fine i can't tell
the battery life yet obviously but this
is something i'll keep you posted on
probably day to day on twitter just in
case anything weird happens i can just
tell you guys about it but like i said
day-to-day performance gaming
performance even it seems fine because
it's running at 1080p anyway the only
minor con actually did find in my time
using the g3 was after using it for a
while the phone wouldn't let me increase
the display's brightness anymore over a
certain amount when the phone heated up
in temperature it didn't happen all that
much but when it did it would notch me
down to 90 or 85 percent to cool down
the graphics i guess by dimming the
display it's an interesting little thing
that i'll be sure to keep my eye on but
really we gotta wait till the apps catch
up here and get optimized i can't wait
to see android games running at the full
2560 by 1440 res i can't wait to see
other apps update with higher res
graphics to look even more stunning
because right now all the benefits you
have really from this display are the
sweet wallpapers the really sharp text
in apps and web browsing and the really
high resolution photo and video playback
so this is something i'll have to give
some more time and check up on but yeah
that's my impressions of the lg g3 for
now turns out this could be one of those
really influential android devices kind
of like the droid dna was where if it
goes well i guess you could expect the
galaxy s5 prime or the htc one m8 prime
to have qhd displays too you never know
we'll see
but these are my impressions of the g3
and the review process begins now thanks
for watching this video i hope many more
to come and i'll talk to you guys in the
next one peace
you